I've
seen the sky
turn
red I lost someone years ago now I'm
looking for him the
world
must I have to keep
trying I don't
suck I'm getting there I'm getting
home
[Music]
ofion it's been so long your phone you
know what it says the Japanese believe a
little bit
longer this is the most powerful
military on the planet yes sir why do
you even think I'm going to go along
with all of this because everything
don't change burn it
all
again we are the last Light of the World
you have to know that this is not the
answer it must
end this isn't everything you don't get
to choose for the world you don't get to
choose for me this is all I have left
this is all you have left too she's not
gone
there has to be a sacrifice it's broken
World sh B the
together we can do
anything but
burn it
all
again